would say his calling card with his
dragon off
well surprise surprise well not really a
surprise he still does use dragon off
quite regularly but
the kuni mitsubic who we saw from out
earlier he has quite the roster of
characters nowadays but uh his kuni
mitsu is definitely one of those ones
where you could feel the strength or the
the essence of strength out of him you
know you can tell when someone plays
very strong with a certain character and
kudimitsu is definitely one of those
characters for ow
he just flows so well into like her back
turn mix-ups her set dashes and nice
punish there
controlling oh wow follows it up
it's the unconventional punishes and
situational stuff that he does with this
character that really surprises me
and we'll see a lot of that he's truly
makes great use of the grounded hit on
the quarter circle forward too and also
certain punishes you'll see it i think
as we go through
he's just so creative you know nobody
yeah nobody has been rocking this
character for so long does that we got
counter hit down two owl is still
marching against the wall
just wants to eliminate all those
options we are seeing novi though just
tack the legs
but ow still in control
i jinxed them is that enough
oh it wasn't enough oh great block into
the rage drive oh man the blender wow
crouch mix-ups yep oh key charge set up
what do we got nobody backing away
he does not want to deal with it all
wanted to go for the counter hit like
mid oh it's that mid hit from that kunai
knife but nobody hanging in there
cancel that out
[Music]
okay how's it going familiar with this
match
i mean if he landed that set two into
the in the counter combo at the end of
that first round that would have been
crazy
yeah it would have been nice
for so long
no bar
yeah still very dominant here as uh
wow the exchange owl has some rage to
work with but no yamasa nobi
just keeping him at bay playing it very
calculated
yeah i like the way he's been playing
you know the way he's approaching the
matchup not really letting al go crazy
and al can go crazy with this character
he just has to find the right openings
oh good stuff
wow
chain it up
and break that arm
you know just dwindling the life of ow
not even able for him to breathe and
nice punish
nobody kind of a rocky first round but
he was able to pull everything together
yeah i like what i'm seeing here uh uh
ow i think has the challenge where he
has to kind of figure out how to break
nobi and how to really get in there
because he really didn't have an
opportunity where you know he was able
to get a reaction out of nobody nobody
was always uh very counterintuitive for
the way he was playing there weren't a
lot of you know missed opportunities you
know everything was either a block or on
hit from nobi so he didn't really get to
steal the flow back from him which is
something that his style excels in is
you know you know he's a lisa player
usually he would back dash or sidestep
and create opportunities for himself he
didn't get to do that with guinea mitsu
in this matchup so uh i wonder if he's
going to try to shift into another
character
and create like you know with with leroy
and maybe with even with bakaram he has
the ability to take more of an offensive
charge and uh whether or not nobody
would be ready for that who knows that
but you have one match
you have two well exactly whoever you
yeah
you're stuck with that character so you
you have one more chance here to kind of
change things up but i wouldn't be
surprised if you stuck tekuni mitsu
yeah
he still has like ways to try to get in
but as you mentioned nobody playing very
stoic right he did not falter in in the
offense of owl even when he went for
that key charge he was like all right
i'm just gonna chill i know that you're
trying to you're trying to bait a
counter hit out of me um you just saw
how patient he was to just um just
weather out that early storm and nobi
like towards the end of those rounds it
was able to exact his offense so can he
still do that
second hit able to land let's see what
kind of
what kind of changes we're going to see
very quickly here from owl but right now
looking a little bit more patient the
way he's approaching here forcing nobody
to go in and looking at the 2-2 mix
tries to go cartwheeling on him but
nobody's still being very cautious with
his approach he knows cooney has some
range with those knives and now yeah
just blocking all the set dashes here
uh oh let's it rip oh my god nice punish
on that warp strike the whiff warp
strike now owl has no more rage to work
with but he does get the kunai throw
round two damn he clipped him there as
he was sidestepping that's crazy
okay second hit
oh he throws back the follow-up here
this is going to be huge for owl gets
the wall
what's the mix what's the mix
oh i think that might have put him in a
bad position no first position now
yeah you know i'm forcing him to move
away nobody has rage now ow still trying
to play the range game backing away but
nobody slowly stalking his prey closing
out that distance down two lands rising
four oh rage drive already spent halfway
through the second round
okay he's now enraged let's see if he
uses the rage drive
goes to the low double hit
and the while 74 follow able to close it
out
up two rounds here trying to turn things
around and it's working out for him so
far
ow answering back here could it be three
rounds straight that would be a huge uh
well
shift of momentum
you see him go for those knee spins just
going low nice punish on outside
he might be dead
yo
okay
nobi once again yeah
nobody's just getting started so let's
see if al can just get that one round
first to just to put one match on the
board for him
nobody doing a great job not being
deterred like knowing when to come in
backing away down two poking away then
just backing up oh gets the tackle
yo he wasn't ready for that
the follow up here good life lead here
from noby nobody's probably going to
calm down a little bit here not take too
much of a risk but al is going to have
to go in
nice slight e
and cooney's got those tools to just uh
close out that distance right nobody has
to be constantly on defense okay gets
the low almost in the life lead is out
okay followed it up with the climbing
shadows lows
he wants to close this one out nobody oh
my god the frost slide lands mark man
able to pull it off and look at that
we're tied up now one apiece
and i feel like the defensive approach
that ao took early on to kind of force
himself to get counter hits here and
there definitely worked out now it's on
nobody to make the adjustment here
because man that's a that's a big change
of pace here
yeah you saw how calculated out was not
really forcing anything just kind of
relaxing going for those pokes i mean
cooney can play the poke game and move
away but you also saw that when nobody
did get that life lead he was trying to
like back up a little bit and that's
when you saw the aggression come out of
owl so
nopey has a big task ahead of him you
know al already made the right
adjustment two rounds straight nobody
was able to bounce back just but now um
yeah momentum is on ali's side
all right as we go into this uh thought
here is is nobody gonna switch
characters do you think there there's an
opportunity or a chance i would even
entertain that you know he's been using
a lot of fenway in tournament lately as
well we'll see i mean i i feel like
fenway has been a lot of players uh
choice recently you know we saw a lot of
marduk for a while now we're seeing a
lot of fenway for more and more people
but he's going to stick to dragon of it
looks like mm-hmm okay probably just a
timing thing he's just gonna change
things up change up his approach uh so
probably yeah maybe the thing will come
out later on maybe even if steve might
come out later on but he is still
sticking a dragon off we're going to suk
so kind of a compact stage here so al
has to be careful with what ground he's
giving up when he's back dashing because
he could find himself with his back
against the wall literally
nice too oh look at this offense
going for the flip over the mix
and here comes nobee
oh great stuff in all the set yeah stuff
in all the set options here
back turn
nice oh gets the grab no he wasn't ready
for that one
yeah grab and stab
oh follow it up
shadows
oh
down forward one
wow
move
oh my gosh that was insane
that was she could do that from like a
crouching position as well so it's it's
actually really insane the things that
she could avoid with that
yeah it's real tricky gets the warp
strike now ow making sure his lead
counts here
nobody's still trying to find his
footing in this matchup
let me see that okay gets the second hit
there
nice movement from nobi
not able to convert to a full combo but
big opportunity here this is the punish
oh enrage
yeah
and something for sure to highlight even
yeah nobody just really just being a
moving target for owl a lot of these
moves have been whiffing for owl so he
has to be very careful with his approach
to nobi
try to hit him with a delay while
standing one one that is safe but there
is a gap in between kind of forcing
nobody to react he got hit by it early
on but not not biting this time oh man
wow
down two to the instant running too
he has the wall positioning it could
look really good here gets the wall
bounce that's going to hurt
as he called it out mark man he reaped
the rewards there down to keeping him at
bay locking him down the movement again
for the down four no be one round away
from sealing the deal and making his way
to winners finals can owl answer back
again very very important here
especially since you're on the winner's
side you do not want to go to losers at
the start of the top eight where it'll
be much longer for you to be able to get
back on top
this is your opportunity to get into the
winners final
oh this is all gonna hit
the step and then follow that up with a
running two nobe moving on it's gonna be
again versus nobi ow going to the
loser's bracket he's still not done yet
ladies and gentlemen but let's let's
talk about that last sequence marvin
it's like nobody's just moving was just
so on point
yeah and nobody didn't really do
anything crazy it was like his classic
dragon off style and he was just able to
kind of outpace and outmaneuver and out
space against al and unfortunately for
ow he's now going to have to take a trip
down to the losers bracket and i think
that's going to be tough because you
know the he's going to be playing
against khari or chikarin or the two
players that he's going to be playing
against and both of those players i mean
we saw